hey guys it's Jan here Tom Hardy gives a
dazzling double performance as twin East
and gangsters Reggie and Ronnie Kray in
the true crime drama legend as Reggie
Hardy is ostensibly all smooth surfaces
and rounded edges a charming veneer that
masks a propensity for ferocious
violence as Ronnie Hardy can go from
quietly spoken candor and Menace to
snarling spitting indignation and
psychopathic rage in the blink of an eye
but even in those quieter moments we
always know that Ronnie is looking for
his next showdown
even without the character's physical
differences Hardy puts in such a strong
turn as each brother that you'd have no
problem telling them apart and the way
the brothers are presented on screen
isn't all about cunning camera
positioning and actor doubles in fact we
often see Hardy as both Reggie and
Ronnie on screen side-by-side in the
same shot of course Hardy's not
the first actor to take on twin roles in
a movie there was army hammer in the
social network Freddie Highmore and
Spiderwick Chronicles and of course
Jeremy Irons in Dead Ringers just to
name a few
and it's not the first time that
Hardee's brought a real-life criminal to
life on the big screen either remember
Drive director Nicolas Winding reckons
super stylized film Bronson back in 2009
when it featured Heidi giving an
insanely bold turn as Britain's most
dangerous prisoner Charles Bronson and
of course Hardy's also made in number of
frames in the crime drama genre already
most recently he played Jewish gang
leader Alfie Solomon's in the BBC period
crime drama peaky blinders and before
that he starred in the fantastic crime
dramas the drop and lawless and then
there was of course layer cake and
RocknRolla too of course none of that
negates what a stellar performance tom
hardy gives in this movie legend as for
the supporting cast well as Reggie's
girlfriends and later wife we've got
sucker punch star Emily Browning and her
delicate features and softly spoken
approach of occasional quiet defiance
works well and on top of that she looks
tiny next to Tom Hardy which makes
Reggie and Ronnie seem even more in
posing in intimidating there's also a
whole raft of brilliant British actors
in supporting roles though some feel
underused given their talent still
that's to be expected as legend is
obviously the Ronnie and Reggie show and
therefore very much the Tom Hardy show
Harry Potter's David Thewlis puts in a
neat turn as a crazed accountant also
look out for Kingsman the Secret Service
star Taron Egerton as Ronnie's lover
Teddy former doctor whose star
Christopher Eccleston as a policeman
after the crazed Paul Bettany is a rival
gang leader and Hardy's peaky blinders
co-star Paul Anderson as one of the
crave gang by the way we'll see Anderson
join Hardy on-screen again shortly in
Gonzales in Yeley twos the revenant and
there's Merlin star Colin Morgan who
plays Francis's brother who's also
Reggie's driver Morgan continues to show
real promise as a film actor and it's
obvious he just needs the right breakout
part now to make a bigger name for
himself in movies legends writer
director Brian Helgeland is best known
for writing loads of screenplays
including the superb LA Confidential
though he's also directed a number of
films such as baseball biopic 42 and the
Knight's Tale starring Heath Ledger
helgeland based this film on author John
Pearson's non-fiction book the
profession of violence the rise and fall
of the Kray twins and I really like the
fact that helgeland drops us right in
the middle of the query story in 1960s
London so we avoid all the usual
childhood scenes and their rise to power
what we get instead is more the
expansion of their power from the east
to the West End and beyond their
aspirations of expanding their empire
still further and of course the events
that led to their eventual downfall and
I also like the way that gangster Jack
the Hat McVitie keeps popping up as a
thorn in the quayside throughout the
film after were introduced to him early
on in legends combo of seemingly
glamorous lifestyle and very unglamorous
violence he'll Berlin has gone for the
feel of a British Martin Scorsese movie
mixed with some of the movies scandal
about the Profumo affair
cares obviously been taken over dressing
both the actors and the sets giving the
film a glossy period
Sheen and plenty of dark humors also
been worked into the storyline too
however there are things though that
aren't really clear or at least seemed
out of place or disjointed in the script
like why does Ronnie seem to be living
in an old beat-up caravan in the woods
at one point also throughout the film we
hear voiceover narration from Francis I
wasn't keen on this framing device as it
seems incongruous given that she wasn't
involved in any way in so many of the
events that she narrates and her
character also ends up feeling more of a
means to an end than a fully written
fleshed out character still it's
interesting that the 1990 film the craze
and this film both find their way into
the brothers story via the women in
their life in the 1990 film the focus
was very much on them the violet whereas
in this latest film violet plays a very
small part and it's Francis who becomes
our guide still I much prefer helgeland
take on the craze to the 1990 film
starring Spandau Ballet brothers Martin
and Gary Kemp for me that whole film
felt melodramatic and really laid on the
symbolism way too thick so to sum up
although legend tells a familiar story
that's been told time and again in print
and on screen over the years writer
director brian helgeland has still
managed to make two hours and ten
minutes of compelling drama of course a
large part of that success is due to Tom
Hardy who puts in a remarkable
performance or rather two remarkable
performances and is a Blee supported by
a talented cast of well-known faces
legend gets three and a half out of 5
flicks now what do you think of legend
and what are your favorite gangster
flicks let me know in the comments below
as ever if you liked this video do
please share it hit the thumbs-up button
and subscribe for my movie reviews and
interviews thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
you